by the end of christopher nolan's
interstellar the audience has fully
versed on what happened to cooper
brand and humanity in general however
there are a lot of smaller details that
are left up to our imaginations
here are some of the biggest questions
we have after watching interstellar
it's obvious that interstellar takes
place in the future although just how
far in the future
it's never clarified we do receive a few
clues that the world of interstellar
isn't tremendously ahead of our own
the characters clothing and housing all
seem to line up with current designs
and while the robotics technology is
certainly more advanced than what we
have today
it doesn't appear to be too far beyond
where we are now in order for the
lazarus missions to have departed 10
years before the start of the film
humans must have made significant
strides in space travel and cryo-sleep
technology a decade before the movie
started at the latest
and cooper looks to be in his late 30s
or early 40s
at the start of the movie which means
that his flashbacks his career as a nasa
pilot
must have taken place within the past
couple decades before the movie began
one theory referencing the book the
science of interstellar extrapolates
that the wormhole near saturn was
discovered in 2019
placing the beginning of the movie
around the year 2067
however this is based on supplemental
material and not the film itself
while this seems like a reasonable guess
based on the information presented in
interstellar we have no way of knowing
for sure
one of the most curious throwaway lines
in interstellar happens early on
when cooper mentions how mri technology
could have saved his late wife
and if we had any of those left the
doctors would have been able to find the
cyst in my wife's brain
before she died and said afterwards no
further elaboration is given about why
mris would have ceased to exist
and it's an odd piece of world building
when you consider that other types of
technology
still appear to be just fine not only
are cars trucks and large farming
equipment still prevalent but the
characters clothing and resources
speak to a manufacturing industry that
is still going strong
and while colleges are now only open to
the very top echelon of students
that's probably because those students
are going into highly educated fields
and it's reasonable to assume medicine
would be among them of course other
forms of technology have been scrapped
on purpose
as part of the scapegoating of nasa
explaining how the apollo missions were
fake to bankrupt the soviet union
in response to the blight that wiped out
most of earth's crops the history books
were rewritten to teach that the moon
landing was faked and that space
exploration was futile
in an effort to keep humanity focused on
fixing the problems of earth
not dreaming of the stars but mri
machines don't seem like they should
have been lumped in with spaceships in
that particular disinformation campaign
since they're used to diagnose patients
here on earth could one of the
gravitational anomalies prior to
interstellar have fried all existing
mri machines simultaneously perhaps but
in that case why not build new ones
interstellar never offers any clarity in
what happened to the life-saving
technology
so we're left to guess at the start of
interstellar
earth's crops have been largely
destroyed thanks to a global blight that
eventually wipes out
every form of plant life it encounters
nelson's torching his whole crop
light they're saying it's the last
harvest for okra
ever corn is one of the only viable
crops that humans have left
but even that will eventually die out
leaving humans with no food source at
all
professor brand mentions at one point
that the blight seems particularly
suited to thrive in earth's largely
nitrogen-based atmosphere
yet the film never provides much more
detail on exactly what the blight is
we don't know if it evolved naturally or
if humans somehow caused it through our
own actions the blight affects every
last person on and off of earth
but how it came to be is left entirely
up in the air
before cooper heads off into space we
get a couple glimpses of what life is
like in interstellar's dusty future
version
of the united states and it begs some
interesting questions about the supply
chain
although the school principle mentions
that most students will grow up to
become farmers
lots of other industries must still be
up and running in order to create the
world in which the coopers live
basic utilities all seem to still exist
and cars seem pretty common
which means that the fuel industry must
still be chugging along
most meals are corn based but the koopas
eat a variety of dishes requiring other
ingredients that they don't seem to grow
on their farm
implying that at least a modest grocery
supply chain is still up and running
their clothes are dusty but intact
so there must be a functional textile
industry as well and perhaps most
bafflingly
there still appear to be professional
sports teams with the money for new
custom uniforms
it causes us to wonder exactly how long
the list of viable professions is
in the world of interstellar and why
everyone talks as if the vast majority
of people are farmers
when the world they live in tells a
different story even in secret
nasa is still an agency run by the
american government so it's unsurprising
that interstellar tells a pretty
america-centric tale
but what's going on in other countries
while professor brand is spending
decades solving his equation to save the
world
surely they're not just sitting around
waiting for the americans to save the
day
but we never get so much as a hint as to
what they are doing cooper does mention
at one point that there are no more
armies
which implies that instead of the
widespread famine prompting war
it has instead incentivized earth's
population to work on the problem
together
he also says that india's space program
was disbanded around the same time as
nasa
delhi mission control went down same as
ours 10 years ago the teacher at merv
school mentions that the revised version
of history claims that the moon landing
was nothing more than soviet propaganda
implying that there's still no love lost
between the two countries although
apparently not enough to warrant
military intervention
by the end of interstellar humanity has
successfully escaped the dying planet
we're meant to understand that this
means that all of humanity was saved but
it sure would have been nice to have
some evidence of life outside of the
future united states
throughout interstellar the characters
encounter various gravitational
anomalies
both big and small by the end of the
film the source of many of these
anomalies has become clear they aren't
anomalies at all
but intelligent acts designed to serve a
specific purpose the humans of the
future referred to only as
they created the wormhole in order to
give the humans of the past and escape
route from earth
cooper himself was responsible for the
various anomalies in his daughter's
childhood bedroom
i figured out the message one word
you know what it is stay
it says stay down however there are a
number of other anomalies referenced in
interstellar that don't appear to have
any clear purpose
such as the one that caused cooper's
instruments to malfunction when he was
working as a test pilot
we started detecting gravitational
anomalies almost 50 years ago
mostly small distortions to our
instruments in the upper atmosphere
what these anomalies were and why they
occurred are never really addressed
it seems reasonable to infer that they
called the anomalies but for what
purpose
was it merely to get humanity's
attention and thus put in motion a
sequence of events leading to the film
or that the past anomalies serve some
sort of other unexplained function that
we never learn about
by the time cooper is finally able to
finally collect and transmit the quantum
data
from the black hole gargantuar to his
daughter murph back on earth
only a few years have passed for cooper
and brand but decades have elapsed on
earth
during that time professor brand has
been tirelessly working on his gravity
equation
although murph later finds out that he'd
known for years it was unsolvable
and was merely trying to give the people
on earth a glimmer of hope until they
eventually suffocated to death in a
degrading atmosphere
however for that entire time professor
brandon murth are working inside the
massive space station orbiting saturn
that we see at the end of the film once
cooper station is in space
we see that its inhabitants are able to
use a space inside it to farm
creating food for the human to have
escaped earth so why weren't they using
the stations for that purpose when they
were still on earth
granted they couldn't have used every
inch of real estate for farming if they
were tied down by gravity
but it seems like they should have been
able to figure out a way to use some of
it
especially given how much time they had
when the endurance leaves earth it's
only been 10 years
since wolf edmunds and the other
scientists first departed on the lazarus
missions
but by the time bran finally makes it to
the planet where he'd set up camp
nearly 90 years have passed and edmunds
has died it's implied that he was killed
when a rock slide destroyed the cryo
chamber in which he was hibernating
although it's also possible that he died
due to a malfunction in the chamber
itself and the rock slide happened
afterward
at edmonds didn't survive until bran was
able to reach his planet
isn't really surprising but what's
interesting is the question of when he
died
although edmunds was only sent to his
planet with two years worth of resources
he could extend that almost indefinitely
with his cryogenic pod
so when brandon the endurance first
emerged from the wormhole 12 years after
edmunds first departed
only a year or two would have passed for
edmonds assuming his pod was still
functioning
even after brandon lost 23 years on the
water planet edmunds could have still
been alive
it's possible that if cooper had taken
bran's suggestion and headed straight to
his planet
they might have arrived in time to save
edmonds although in that case
cooper might not have gotten the data
that saves the rest of humanity
when the endurance departs on its
mission they're heading to a system in a
distant galaxy
with three potentially habitable planets
based on the data sent back from three
of the astronauts on the lazarus mission
however 12 astronauts originally
departed 10 years earlier
with a mission to each explore one of 12
possible worlds they all knew that the
chances of their world being able to
support human life were slim
and that if their planet wasn't a good
candidate for relocation but they'll be
on their
own for the rest of their lives however
while it's implied that none of the
other nine wells the lazarus astronauts
visited were viable
and that those astronauts eventually
died we don't actually know that for
sure
it's possible that one or more of the
planets was viable but something
happened to the astronauts or their
equipment
before they could send back their thumbs
up that would send nasa to them
it's even possible that one or more of
the astronauts are still slumbering away
in cryosleep
not really living but not truly dead
either throughout interstellar humanity
receives help from
them mysterious beings that the
scientists of nasa assume must be
benevolent extraterrestrials
however by the end of the film cooper
realizes that they aren't aliens at all
but actually they're humans of the
future who have figured out a way to
exist
and to navigate in five dimensions this
creates a bootstrap paradox in which the
existence of the humans of the future
depends on them already existing to help
the humans of the past but that's easy
enough to explain in the world of
interstellar where time may not actually
be linear at all
what we don't know is exactly how far in
the future these five-dimensional humans
are
or if they even exist in a specific time
at all once merv solves professor
brand's gravity equation
it opens up a whole new world for
humanity not only are they able to
escape their dying planet
but they're able to thrive in new ways
that they never could unearth perhaps
murph's breakthrough is precisely what
lays the groundwork for these new future
humans
meaning that they're not as far ahead of
the humans aboard cooper station as one
might think
then again it could take centuries or
even millennia for humans to evolve to
that point
at the beginning of interstellar
cooper's two children murph and tom
function as pretty typical siblings
neither best friends nor mortal enemies
but simply two kids who mostly get along
and occasionally get under each other's
skin
all that changes though when cooper
leaves aboard the endurance merv spends
the next few decades nursing a grudge
against her father
while tom does his best to remain in
touch even long after cooper stops
responding
during that time tom marries and has two
children but his oldest dies a few years
later of complications
due to the dust-saturated atmosphere
murph meanwhile throws herself into a
work with professor brandt and rarely
visits home
but eventually returns to try to
convince tom to move his family out of
their old farmhouse and underground with
her
when tom refuses murph decides to trick
him throwing him away so she can
essentially kidnap his family
she doesn't actually manage to leave
before tom returns and by then she's
realized she has what she needs to solve
the gravity equation and save humanity
but while murph gives her brother a
relieved hug upon his return
tom doesn't look nearly as ready to bury
the hatchet despite
merv's great accomplishment for humanity
the action she took with her brother's
family significantly overshot the
boundaries he'd set
but we never see tom again after that
making us wonder if the end justified
the means for him
or whether merv's actions damage their
relationship permanently
after cooper emerges from the black hole
they drop him off near saturn
right where a ranger from cooper station
is passing by to pick him up
while it's only been a few minutes for
cooper since he jettisoned himself from
the endurance in order to send brand
onto edmonds planet
it's been over 60 years for the people
of earth due to the time slippage in
gargantuar even if it took a while for
merv to actually implement a solved
equation and launched the space stations
humans have had decades in which to find
a new home
and yet cooper station and others like
it are still content to just float
around near saturn
despite never having received conclusive
data about the world just on the other
side of the wormhole
we know the wormhole still exists since
that's how cooper returns to brand at
the end of the film
as far as nasa knows one of those
planets from the lazarus mission
could still be a viable new home world
it's understandable that they wouldn't
want to send an entire station through
as a guinea pig but why not send a few
rangers after the endurance went silent
it seems like by the time brand arrived
on edmond's planet a whole human colony
could have already been set up and ready
to go
and she wouldn't have had to be alone at
all check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stuff are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one